Now that we have seen that some dependencies can
become hazards in our pipeline, now we need to see
how to handle these hazards, so that we still get
correct execution in our pipeline. because we cannot just allow
the pipeline to produce incorrect results. We need to handle
only the situations that are hazards. We don't really care
about dependencies that can never become hazards. In fact, what
we need to do is detect hazard situations, and then
either flash dependent instructions from the pipeline,
stall dependent instructions in the pipeline, so that
the read is delayed and they get the correct value, or even fix values that were
read already by the dependent instructions, so that
we feed them the right value and they
proceed unharmed through the pipeline. We need to
use flushes for control dependencies, because the instructions
we have in the pipeline after a controlled
dependence becomes a hazard, are the wrong instructions.
So delaying them or trying to fix the
values that they are reading is not going to work.
Pretty much, we have to delete these instructions
from the pipeline and fetch the correct ones, and
then execute them from scratch. So, we need
to flush the dependent instructions on a control dependence.
If we have a data dependence, we can stall the subtract, so that it stays in the
stage where it would read R1. Until, finally, the add deposits that value in the
register. So, for hazards caused by data dependencies,
we do not have to flush, we can
simply stall. For some data dependencies, we can
even forward the value of R1 produced by the
add, to the subtract in a way that fixes
the value read by the subtract. Let's consider our
five-stage pipeline and just worry about the stage where
we read the registers and the ALU stage. In
a cycle where the subtract is reading the registers,
the add is in the ALU stage. At the
end of this cycle, the subtract has read the
wrong register value for R1 because R1 still doesn't have
what add will eventually write to it. But the add at the end of this cycle has
the value, it's just that it didn't put it in R1 yet. What we now can do is at
the beginning of the following cycle, subtract can get
the value that the add produced, and that value
replaces the value that we read from R1 so
that subtract computes with the correct value. So pretty
much, if the value exists somewhere in the
pipeline, at the point before we actually use
the value to compute, we can fix what we have read so that we still compute with
the right value. This is called forwarding, and
it amounts to pretty much fixing the values
read by dependent instructions. Forwarding does not always
work. Sometimes the value we need will be produced
at the later point in time so at the time we need it to compute, we still don't
even have that value in the pipeline. At that
time we need to stall instead of forwarding. So basically,
for control hazards we need to flush. For some
data hazards we can either stall it forward, and
we prefer forwarding because it doesn't introduce stalls in
the pipeline. And for some data hazards, at least some
stalls are necessary.